Те, що вони інкримінують, ну, це .. в нормальному демократичному суспільстві… це не те що смішно .
Це нікчемно!
Якби мені тоді сказали, що попереду три роки, я не знаю…
А ось коли тобі вдягають пакет на голову - темно. То є небезпека. І ось зараз я не можу прийти до тями.
Але ні хвилини у мене не було сумніву, що я буду вільна, що я буду у своїй Україні…
Я - Гусейнова Людмила. Мені 60 років. Я три роки була в полоні на окупованій території.
Мене затримали за мої проукраїнські, націоналістичні, як вони казали, погляди.
І за ту допомогу, яку я надавала дітям, які проживали на окупованих територіях.
Все почалося у 14 році, у моєму місті ще не було якихось дій. Але потім так сталося, що ця біда накрила й наше місто.
Хто зміг - поїхав. А ми залишилися, тому що не вірили, що так довго буде.
Ми сподівалися, ну, ми протримаємося - трішки, трішки і все буде добре, і все станеться так, як повинно статися.
І якщо ми поїдемо, то все, всі скажуть, то вже все. То вже України тут не буде ніколи.
Бо всі знали, які погляди у мене, моєї сімʼї.
А потім я дізналася, що не виїхав дитячий інтернат, який при Україні був,
працював в Приморському селі нашого района.
Так сталося, що припинили фінансувати цей інтернат, не було кому там працювати.
І тих дітей роздали в ті сімʼї, які не мали достатку або щось таке, утримувати цих дітей.
Я коли в перший раз це дізналася, я поїхала, я була шокована.
Тому що діти не доїдали. Дітям не було чого одягти.
Ми вирішили, що будемо робити все можливе, щоб допомагати цим дітям.
Я звернулася до своїх знайомих, рідних, які проживали на звільненій території України.
Ми навіть не очікували, скільки людей, навіть не знайомих нам, скільки людей прийняли участь в житті цих дітей.
Ми тим дітям дали розуміння, що за ту лінію розмежування не вороги для них.
А там живуть люди, які приймуть їх, і які про них памʼятають.
І я думаю, що навіть зараз, коли ми не бачили цих дітей вже 3 роки, коли я не знаю, як склалася їхня доля,
я думаю, що навіть зараз та частинка любові і доброти до громадян України у серцях цих дітей залишилася.
І знайте, що ця любов - вона залишилася на окупованій території. Попри все.
Мене забрали по дорозі на роботу. Щойно я вийшла з двору, підʼїхала машина, вискочили 2 хлопці.
Почали дивитися телефон. Забрали мене у свою контору. Я не відчувала, що щось таке страшне сталося.
Я думала - ну що, ну телефон. Ви знаєте, яка я. Я відкрито не виходжу на площу.
Нікого ні до чого не закликаю, з автомата не стріляю. Такі у мене погляди - я їх не змінювала.
Ви про це знали. Я думала, що або штраф якийсь випишуть, або 15 діб арешту.
Або скажуть: так, ось тобі 5 годин і до побачення.
Вони коли у мене забрали той телефон, вони одразу зайшли у Фейсбук і почали мені показувати…
Ви розумієте, те, що вони інкримінують, ну, це .. в нормальному демократичному суспільстві… це
не те що смішно . Це нікчемно!
Бо я писала, що дуже вдячна всій країні, що вони допомагають дітям,
які перебувають на окупованій території.
І з цього допису слово "окупованій" також було лінгвістично досліджено якимось там експертом.
І це невизнання республіки, приниження жителів республіки, тим, що я їх не визнаю.
Ось така маячня! Ось просто за 5 років - з 2014 по 2019, вони знайшли близько 50-ти епізодів,
із них більшу частину я просто лайкнула, які вони вважають, що за 5 років 50 епізодів,
котрі вони вважають, що ті підпадають під їхню статтю про екстремізм ,
невизнання влади і шпіонаж. У відкритій фейсбучній сторінці.
Я ще не знала, де я. І коли мене в камеру впихнули, зняли повʼязку, дівчина була там, вона сказала: то "Ізоляція".
І я до цього читала про ту "Ізоляцію". Тоді мені стало дуже лячно, скажімо так.
Я до речі, дуже боялася, що в мене буде адвокат. Це було ще в Ізоляції.
Дівчата розповідали, що там є "каста" так звана адвокатів, котра співпрацює з так званим "МГБ".
Інших не допускають. Або допускають, але не дуже.
І якщо дівчата не відмовилися від адвокатів, котрих наймали родичі або щось таке. Їх бʼють.
Тобто примушують відмовитися від адвокатів. У нас у камері Марина була. Її мама найняла адвоката,
заключила договір,  оплату зробила тому адвокату.
Її привезли до слідчого,  а той каже: "Ось зараз візьмеш ручку і скажеш, що ти від нього відмовляєшся".
Вона: "Чого це так?" "Ти не розумієш, чого це так?" Зайшли опера,вивели її в туалет і били допоки, поки вона не зрозуміла, чому це так.
І коли мене привезли до слідчого, це вже понад місяць я була на "Ізоляції".
Везуть, звісно, наряд той самий. В пакет… Пакет, да. Або целофановий, такий тобі, але не прозорий, щоб ти нічого не бачила.
Або мішок з мішковини на голові. Пакет ти знімаєш тільки у слідчого. Привели мене до слідчого, той називає прізвище, каже, питає: "Хто це?".
Я не знаю, хто це, і це правда. Він каже, що ваші рідні найняли вам адвоката.
Я дуже налякалася, бо думаю, як мені групуватися, бо зараз почнуть або тут бити, або поведуть… Як краще...
Почала щось пригадувати з юнацьких років, як краще падати, як групуватися, тому що це страшно. Але на щастя, мій адвокат якось зміг з ними домовитися.
Його залишили. І він мені одразу сказав, що ви розумієте, ми в такій системі живемо... Ну, що, що вам можуть...
Ви просто щось лайкнули або щось сказали. Але розраховувати на те, що це все закінчиться виправданням, не має сенсу. Цього не буде.
Такого не було, жодного епізоду за весь цей час.
Він сказав, що ваші рідні подали на обмін,
і ось, давайте уже потерпимо трохи, там декілька місяців. Може, до Нового року і якось наладиться.
Я цьому дуже зраділа, ну два місяці, Боже, ну якось уже проходжу у тому пакеті. Якби мені тоді сказали, що попереду три роки, я не знаю…
Я не знаю, чи варто було б мені тоді це знати.
Так, ми жили весь час, з дівчатами чекали. Добре, ну, ось, зараз. Якщо не Новий рік, то може, Пасха. А може, Різдво.
А може, якісь ми там ставили собі межі, що під великі свята. Ось зараз це відбудеться. Ну якось ось ми прожили ці три роки.
Я в перші дні… Там не можна до 10-ої години вечора сідати або ж лягати на нару.
У мене був другий поверх, так сталося, доволі висока нара, і там штир ще якийсь залізний з тієї нари. Ну я так втомилася, це були перші дні…
Цілий день ти ходиш або стоїш - важко з 6-ої години ранку до 10-ої години вечора. І я без пʼяти десята вирішила все ж таки лягти на нару.
А ти навіть в камері, коли відчиняються двері, маєш одягати того пакета, і обличчям до стіни ставати. І різко відчиняються двері. Брудні слова.
Я одягаю пакета, сідаю на ту нару, бо я не знаю, як .. я роздягнута. Цей охоронець скидує мене з другого поверху нари. Я падаю, було боляче.
І так мене привчили, що там не можна порушувати ті норми, які вони встановили.
Я зараз сиджу з вами - не те що я боюся, що темно.. Але за 3 роки я звикла, щодобове світло в камерах.
А ось коли тобі вдягають пакет на голову - темно. То є небезпека. І ось зараз я не можу прийти до тями.
Тому що коли темно - треба групуватися.
Ви знаєте, я чесно скажу, що я щось блокую. І навчилася це робити там, бо якщо ти про це завжди думаєш або памʼятаєш, ти не можеш цього страху забути.
А цього не треба робити. Перше, що треба робити, потрапивши в такі місця, в "Ізоляцію", в тюрму, абощо - це переломити себе настільки,
вивернути, і зробити так, щоб ти нікого не боялася. Бо якщо хоч здрихнешся, або хоч покажеш, що ти боїшся, то все -
тебе просто знесуть, зібʼють і будуть знущатися ще більше.
Вільного доступу не мав до мене адвокат. Якщо слідчий викличе, і якщо при цьому адвокату зателефонує, щоб адвокат прийшов.
І тому я дуже просила, щоб мене перевели в тюрму, бо там є вже інший порядок, якісь інші закони.
Це вже зустрічав мене охоронець із СІЗО, у мене було таке щасливе обличчя, а він каже: "Жіночка, що з вами?".
Ви йдете в тюрму і ви такі раді! А я була рада, бо я по території тюрми пересувалася без пакета на голові. Я хоч бачила обличчя.
Я побачила сонце вперше, мабуть, за два місяці. Я вже не боялася, що мені, як то кажуть, прилетить, з будь-якої сторони.
Тобто навіть СІЗО воно для мене було краще, ніж та "Ізоляція".
Я така щаслива, що я вирвалася з тієї Ізоляції. Зайшла в саму тюрму, і там … запах. Ти відчуваєш запах тюрми.
Мені досі здається, що я ще не вимилася від нього. Відчиняються двері, такі невелички.. І там менше, ніж це приміщення камера.
Там 5 двоярусних спарених між собою нар. І 20 .. зі мною вже стало 20 жінок.
Вони всі курять. Вони варять там на кип'ятильнику якогось борща і роблять зажарку.
І там тряпочкою в куточку така занавіска з тряпки, а за тієї занавіскою невеличка раковина і дірка в підлозі. То є туалет.
І над цим туалетом ти маєш митися, вмиватися, чистити зуби. Бо над раковиною не можна, і це обговорювалося спеціально.
Бо серед тих 20 жінок там майже половина вони хворі на СНІД. І ти розумієш, що там проблеми з зубами, якісь там рани, щось таке.
То усі чистили зуби над тією діркою в туалеті. Ми закривали ту дірку пляшкою із води, наливали якусь просту воду і закривали ту дірку, бо
звідтіля могли і криси вискакувати. Й такий сморід ішов, що неможливо було.
Я дуже довго… не звикала до цього, а звикала не звертати на це увагу. Не дихати повними грудьми.
Тому що цей сморід вдихати неможливо було.
Це брудне життя. Бо цей бруд - у тих розмовах, котрі…
У тому повітрі. У тому туалеті. Я собі казала "треба це пережити". Старатися не занурюватися у свої проблеми, переживання.
Мені зараз самій важко уявити, як я це пережила. І все, були такі моменти з відчаю. Звісно, були такі моменти відчаю, коли ти маєш надію, ти чекаєш,
що зараз щось трапиться. Навіть не те, що я сумнівалася, що зараз я буду обміняна, або я буду в Україні.
Ми з дівчатами деякими мріяли, що двері зараз відкриються і наші прийшли, наші! І ми все, ми вільні. Або обмін. Я не сумнівалася в цьому.
Але були моменти втоми, емоційної, фізичної втоми. Відчаю. І ти засинаєш…
Якісь там беруші в вуха, щось там валерʼянку випиваєш, намагаєшся заснути, закрити очі. І ти боїшся зранку ці очі відкрити, бо ти побачиш те саме!
І це дуже… дуже тяжко було, скажімо так. Але ні хвилини у мене не було сумніву, що я буду вільна, що я буду у своїй Україні, що я буду поруч зі своїми.
Я про що хочу сказати - відношення до "укропів". Ну звісно, в перші декілька місяців було таке відношення "укропка".
Щойно я зайшла, вони сказали: "О, ще одна укропка зʼявилася в камері". Коли почалася війна, там був телевізор - ми майже цілодобово…
той телевізор не вимикався.  І напередодні виступав той Путін з промовою, бо всі передачі перестали, тільки його показували.
І всі завмерли і мовчки слухали, бо це було страшно.
І вже після прогулянки, я щось там читала, відчиняються двері, і мені дають 20 хвилин на збори. Не пояснюючи нічого.
Дівчина, котра там залишилася, Оля, вона сказала - мені здається, що це то саме. Але вона залишалася, а я уходила.
Я теж про це казала, у неї маленька дитина. Її забрали також за лайки. Вона не вела якусь активну діяльність.
Але просто лайкала, виражала свої позиції в соціальній мережі, може, щось писала. Коли її забрали, то було два роки тому. Її дитині молодшій було 4 роки.
І вона так дивилася на мене, що мені стало… Ну, якби був у мене такий вибір або така можливість, то я б ще залишилася, щоб її забрати звідтіля.
І я зверталася до всіх і казала про це - мені важко зараз лягати в чисту постіль. Чи, вибачте, у ванній бути.
Бо я знаю, що та Оля так і над тією дірочкою миється. Лягає в постіль брудну від клопів і смороду. І не знає, що там її дитина.
Десь в обід нас знову вивели в мішках. Були вузькі такі коридори, дівчатам було погано. Знову скотчем замотали руки, очі.
Знову погрузили в ту машину, ми так їхали дуже довго. А потім супроводжуючі нас хлопці сказали, що вони є російські військові, і що ми на території Росії.
Що нас привезли в Таганрог. Знову почали трохи плакати дівчата, бо …. Але вони не сказали, що то обмін,
тому що якщо в перші часи ми думали - та, то обмін. Але зараз уже такі сумніви були дуже великі, бо ми не розуміли, що діється.
Вигрузили і нас посадили в літак, він був грузовий, ми не бачили, але зрозуміли.
І нас з іншими дівчатами, уже військовополоненими, яких привезли іншими машинами, сказали сідати на підлогу того літака. І сідати "йолочкою".
Тобто ти роздвигаєш ось так ноги і до тебе сідає інша жінка. І це нас ну майже ногами впихували так.
І ти не маєш можливості ніяк поворушитися, отак декілька рядів. І дівчата там плакали, бо це дуже боляче.
Але ти нічого не можеш зробити, ти ось так сидиш, тією йолочкою.  Дякувати богу, ми години за 2 прилетіли, і вже з цього літака ми виповзали.
І ми побачили, що ми в Джанкої. Що ми їдемо кудись. І все це було незрозуміло до останньої хвилини, куди нас везуть.
Коли була зупинка, ми вже самі познімали ці скотчі з себе, нам дозволили вийти. За прізвищами викликали, поставили, і тоді ми вже пішли.
Побачили хлопця з цим білим прапором. І ми йшли і кричали "Слава Україні - Героям Слава!" І співали гімн.
І це зворушливі на все життя емоції, котрі не може перебити нічого. І ти зрозумів, що все, страшне - там, залишилося позаду.
До того, що залишилося позаду, але я знаю, що там залишилися дівчата, котрі мріють про цю свободу. Котрі мріють сказати ті слова вільно і голосно.
І про котрих я дуже прошу не забувати, і від кого це залежить - зробіть усе можливе і неможливе,
але ці дівчата повинні бути на волі, а їх діти повинні бути разом із ними.